one of the heaviest burdens a parent can
carry abdulrahman rimawi walks his sons
to their final resting place
vafaranjawad were shot during
confrontations with Israeli forces
raiding koforain Village near Ramallah
last week the Israelis said Palestinians
hurled rocks and Molotov cocktails at
the soldiers valver was killed first
in this video he can be heard calling
out to his brother for help
doesn't hesitate more gunfire and he's
dead too
since the beginning of the year wakes
like this one have been held almost
daily across the occupied West Bank
Jawad didn't want to grow bold he loved
his hair look at him he bought hair oils
and would ask me every day if he had
grown baby here is this the attitude of
someone who wanted to die they loved
life but death is imposed on us
those who haven't lost a loved one have
lost the little sense of security they
once had
was driving back home from his Studio
several weeks ago when he was shot near
an Israeli checkpoint south of nebulus
he says the wounds you can see are the
ones that hurt most
we're not worth anything to them ask
anyone who was almost killed I was on my
way home they turned my life upside down
I still don't know why I was shot
the UN says 2022 has been the deadliest
in the occupied West Bank in 16 years
most of the Palestinians killed by
Israeli forces this year were shot in
either Nablus or Janine in both cities
Palestinian Fighters put their political
affiliations aside and took up arms
against the Israeli occupation a
phenomena Israeli official sphere might
ignite similar actions elsewhere and and
in widespread protests Israel says it's
facing an increased threat with three
times the number of Palestinian attacks
this year compared to 2021
Israel bet that security coordination
agreements and playing the Palestinian
Authority could contain any Uprising but
that's impossible given there's an
active occupation that's trying to
create an irreversible fact and settle
the conflict so the question should not
be why this is happening now but why not
sooner throughout the decades long
Israeli occupation Palestinians have
changed their tools of resistance the
one constant has been Defiance Rania
zabane al-jazeera nablis occupied West
Bank